l'image est restée dans les mémoires
marteau piqueur en main denis coderre
démoli la dalle d'une future boîte aux
lettres communautaire le message qu'on
envoie aujourd'hui c'est que postes
canada vont nous respecter citoyens
travailleurs des postes parti
d'opposition en 2015
ils ont dit non au plan de postes canada
nous engageons à rester serré son
domicile la promesse est à moitié tenue
et 4 million deux cent mille ménages
canadiens qui voient encore le facteur
chaque jour garderont leurs services sur
le plateau mont royal
on est content c'est plus facile pour
tout le monde fuit elle évoque sa salle
s'est pas vraiment beau donc moi je
contemple ce que j'aime mieux avoir mal
chez moi que kate option de sortie pour
aller faire plus mal
mais dans tous ses secteurs ou des
boîtes postales ont déjà été installées
les résidents devront continuer de
marcher pour aller chercher leur
courrier
en tout plus de 800 mille ménages au
pays sont concernés nous ne reviendrons
pas en arrière dit la ministre
quoi tout ça coûterait des centaines de
millions de dollars qui ont dit
n'importe quoi
ils ont pas capable aujourd'hui de
répondre à leurs propres promesses ça ne
fait encore une fois que augmenter le
cynisme des électeurs et des électrices
qui vont penser que évidemment les
promesses électorales
ça vaut rien c'est clair que nous on va
continuer cette lutte là on veut que
l'ensemble de peau de la population
récupère son service postal porte à
porte
c'est tellement contraint à se rendre à
des boîtes postales
c'est impensable teyssen daverat qu'on
ne recule pas dans ce quartier de
dollard des ormeaux le courrier est
déposée aux boîtes postales depuis deux
ans dans mon budget
beaucoup de monde si les par sa logique
et comme prévu le 18 il ya beaucoup de
la glace d asi pas facile pour le monde
peuvent alerter
mais ils sont nombreux comme louise
dugas à ne pas vouloir revenir en
arrière
moi ça me force à prendre la marche moi
j'aime ça venir chercher mon courrier ça
me fait rencontrer les voisins apporte
cette décision d'ottawa de cesser
l'implantation de boîtes postales
communautaires pour toute la population
même quand même à se poser des questions
sur la viabilité financière de postes
canada
ce projet convient de freiner prévoyait
des économies de 350 millions de dollars
par année
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
saint lambert